hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna I'm just checking in on you
seeing how your week's going how you
guys doing I am in a great mood I'm in
an awesome mood not you in a bad mood
you're driving in your car you're stuck
in traffic is this some douche in front
of you huh not doing what you want them
to do oh you having a little dictator
thoughts they thinking about what you
would do if you were in power what you
would do with this person what rule you
would implement yeah it's got to be
awesome being a dictator you know what I
mean how much fun is it on the 4th of
July to shoot off fireworks can you
imagine how much fun that fatty over in
North Korea's having you know how hard
did they [ __ ] laugh when they shot
that one over Japan I mean Jesus Crimea
how the [ __ ] did everybody had to go to
bed after that then he's just laying in
bed so [ __ ] amped up like it's crazy
down a whole country calling each other
up
what a [ __ ] lunatic what if there was
a malfunction on that [ __ ] thing and
you just it landed that guy I'm telling
you man he's got to lay off the [ __ ]
sweets all that sugar is just seized
it's not [ __ ] it's not doing him good
he's not making sound decisions thank
God we have such a level-headed guy on
our side oh my god you know watching the
dead zone was always scary watching the
Martin Sheen character get into power
but I think to go back and watch it now
is gonna be just picturing Donald Trump
going the birds are away gentlemen and
doing that little thing he does what he
puts his index finger and his thumb
together this other three fingers are in
the air the birds of the way the
greatest birds
yeah Jesus Christ all this [ __ ] ended
a [ __ ] talking about these goddamn
tornadoes one after another you know
like some battle royal of [ __ ]
weather I did Rogan show last night
there's nothing worse than hanging out
with somebody who's [ __ ] informed he
starts out man this thing was forming
out over the Atlantic they've never seen
anything like this this is the size of
[ __ ] Florida hey Bill how much time
do you want to do tonight I was in a
[ __ ] panic he was like laughing at me
go look at bills face look at bills face
it's like Joe what look am I supposed to
have on my face when you basically said
you know everything you had everything
but Jesus [ __ ] crowd surfing in on
that [ __ ] thing not to mention I'm
going to Mississippi and Alabama this
weekend man with a heart I'm gonna tell
you something right now he's a [ __ ]
northern white boy Yankee I [ __ ] love
Mississippi and Alabama I love that
whole [ __ ] stretch of the south how
they all [ __ ] on each other and then it
somehow lands in Louisiana's lap right
you're in Georgia and all they do is
make fun of Alabama right
Alabama's like [ __ ] Georgia oh hey at
least we're not Mississippi and
Mississippi it's like what the [ __ ] do
you want from us huh why'd you go to
Shreveport tell me how you [ __ ] enjoy
that I love it down that granted I'm
[ __ ] white you don't even if the Klan
started marching you know and I got all
[ __ ] nervous I could fake my way
through it you know give him a nod you
don't slip into a store real quick
anyways I don't know if I mentioned this
the other day I started playing catch
again you know something I used to do as
a kid good clean fun you just need a
glove a ball and a friend maybe a
baseball kid
baseball kid baseball he'd it's just
been a good time this is how old I am I
did 45 minutes of cardio and I guess I
didn't stretch I thought I stretched and
I went out there and old Billy [ __ ]
old face does not have the range of
motion he used to have and my buddy
threw the ball and
bounced in front of me and just sort of
was skidding along the ground and I bent
down to get it I anticipate it was gonna
hop I don't know what I was doing or I
just didn't get down far enough and went
right by my glove and hit right my left
ghost white calf and it only hurt as
much as it should have hurt like a
baseball however fast it was traveling
me and hit the ground it slowed down a
little bit me that nice sound against my
alabaster [ __ ] right then I thought I
was fine and within like three throws my
calf just [ __ ] tightened up like you
couldn't believe and for the like the
last three days it's felt like it's on
fire
alright like if you thought of my like
if they were gonna do a documentary on
my calf they would go to Van Halen one
and they would take that clip from David
Lee Roth singing I'm on fire it's been
[ __ ] killing me so I gotta have I
don't not gonna have somebody [ __ ]
work it out but my buddy gave me this
[ __ ] um this is a free advertisement
this is how [ __ ] good these guys are
it's called arnicare gel never heard of
the stuff it's it's homeopathic what'd
you call me homeopathic medicine
arnicare it's for muscle pain and
stiffness swelling from injuries and
bruising I got a pain relief this [ __ ]
I'm telling you it's [ __ ] magic I put
this stuff on I felt like I was Bionic
you know like like in that you could
just fix me like a machine one of those
one of those [ __ ] Moonraker movies
blade run or whatever the [ __ ] it is
like they would just open my calf and it
looked like the inside of a [ __ ]
miksa I just felt like that they just
that thing just soldered a couple wires
wires together I mean it didn't cure me
I mean I definitely feel like now I just
feel like I got hit with a golf ball
rather than a baseball you know at the
end of a drive I'm not saying right off
the teeth let's not get crazy here okay
let's not get crazy so anyways that's
the free thing I'll tell you right now
if you [ __ ] ever do something before
you go to a masseuse and have them
[ __ ] unglue your muscles and get all
that schmutz out of there my person says
our neck
Kjell AR and I care arnicare like Arnold
Palmer except it's I AR ni well Arnie's
iar nie yeah why don't you confuse the
people say go I had to do with something
free massage because I lost another
advertiser I can't believe it I put my
[ __ ] heart and soul into these
[ __ ] reads you know I could go
monotone I could just read what they
wrote I could just go but you're not
gonna listen and I know this show must
go on even if I'm reading [ __ ]
advertising but those [ __ ] [ __ ] over
there
the masseuse people that was a
one-and-done how dare you bring up
handjobs bet the bet the end of them of
the massage reads what the [ __ ]
you're talking about that's a huge part
of your industry either you're doing it
or you're not doing it the [ __ ] that's
like you were you're in food you're
selling some sort of food and I bring up
trans fat like that's not a big [ __ ]
issue that is a hot-button issue that
debt is dead that needs to be brought up
in front of Congress when I stand by
that if you can legalize weed at a state
level you should be able to legalize a
[ __ ] at the state level okay now if
the feds come in and she's got your dick
in her hand you're on your own
alright you're on your [ __ ] on your
Joe Pesci in Goodfellas Oh No
right that's it that's it
alright ladies it doesn't mean anything
to us it doesn't mean anything if you
ever saw the look on the woman's face
when she's doing it I mean I swear to
God I swear to God like it's just like
she's I don't know what she did thinking
a [ __ ] zillion other things which is
probably usually where you got it's
probably a safe place you know when
you're [ __ ] employed in the sex
industry know what the [ __ ] to tell you
I want to tell you so because I brought
that up which was funny enough to make
people listen they walked away from all
the [ __ ] massages that my listener
would have got now I'm not gonna lie to
ya third of them would have been
expecting some sort of hand release at
the end of it so maybe maybe that's okay
I'll take that okay I will take that
part of it all right but I'm getting
tired of these these deeds of the blue
aprons the nature boxes you know they're
all good when the sun's out in the
second they see a little bit of rough
water what do they do they [ __ ] pull
up stakes those [ __ ] phony bastards
okay and they take their aprons and
their [ __ ] [ __ ] and they go to
somebody else's podcast and I'll tell
you right now I've had enough of it
doing my gosh darn just over here to try
to put a little bit of money in your
pocket you know how many people do you
think at that [ __ ] massage place I've
actually gone to a massage parlor and
gotten [ __ ] jerked off how many you
know what I mean [ __ ] out jeez don't
know give me a [ __ ] story you know I
got in the oh my dog's back in town old
Cleo who's back in town I just saw her
she [ __ ] freaked out we had a nice
little battle royal I took him for this
awesome [ __ ] hike love that goddamn
dog and I love that she's got a great
family now family maybe she and I just
put on a little bit of weight these new
people they're they're uh they're
treating her right but she looked
awesome and same old dog dragging me
down the street all friggin excited and
that type of stuff so it all worked out
nice happy and she's got a little more
white whiskers around her muzzle you
know becoming very distinguished and
stately these last couple of bump you
know last I know I gave away almost a
year ago [ __ ] unbelievable nine
months ago ten months ago nine months
ago yeah and I must go so it was great
to see her and everything so she's in
town for like ten days I'm leaving for a
couple days but that's what I do when
she comes to town to take for a hike
every morning it's kind of been working
out I get to see her every couple of
months you know she's not around where
she can eat my baby or attack somebody
else so she'll never get put down and I
won't have to deal with an unbelievable
amount of guilt and she's got a great
house and she's you know she's fattening
up
it's [ __ ] perfect I love it she's not
fat people I'm just saying she is living
a good life full of energy still a ball
a muscle though good lord that's a
strong dog
I still miss the hell out of her but I
definitely made the right decision so
anyways what's going on tonight all the
Patriots yeah no your [ __ ] wife
[Applause]
football season is back baby
ignore the hurricane sorry just point
yours ignore the Hurricanes ignore old
fatty up there [ __ ] doesn't that
[ __ ] guy at North Korea doesn't look
like he's the same shape as like curly
from the [ __ ] Three Stooges you know
I'd love to see me they think just
reshot the old football sketch you know
could somebody please do that just
Florida sort of photoshopping when
they're doing that thing where he does
that running in place thing all right
doing that whole thing just put his head
on curlies [ __ ] body that's what he's
he's Kim Jong Howard how many times
would I be put to death in that [ __ ]
country I can't even [ __ ] imagine I
can't even imagine you know you got to
go out swinging you got to go out like a
[ __ ] you know you know I'm not you
know Saddam was a [ __ ] brutal guy but
did you see how that guy went out he was
standing there he's just stare at him
all in the eye they put the rope around
his neck he's still talking [ __ ] yeah go
[ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself you know
it's [ __ ] any people always talk
about do when you went Philly how did
you handle that [ __ ] down look at what
Saddam handled he was talking [ __ ] right
until they [ __ ] yanked that rope or
that lever or whatever I've been crying
like a little girl going I'm sorry
[Applause]
sweep the streets yeah that's how I
would have gone out gone into the next
world and God would have just been
looking at me shaking his head you know
of all the awful [ __ ] things you did
I think you're [ __ ] way you left
what's the worst get out of my sight and
they just pushes the button I go down to
health I go down a hill and I burn
forever and that's a good [ __ ] thing
to bring up when you got two gigs coming
up Mississippi and Alabama I'm gonna
tell you you go down Mississippi Alabama
little [ __ ] ain't got the puter
[ __ ] ain't got computers I'll tell you
they still eat they still eat and I
don't till you give him some clothes
line they'll catch a catfish and dry
your overalls [ __ ] they could
live off the land you know if what Rogan
was telling me was even remotely true
him and Jimmy Dora are the two most
informed [ __ ] comedians I know as far
as they actually pay attention to [ __ ]
somebody says some [ __ ] and rather than
just taking it as truth they actually
will [ __ ] research it they'll have
guests on their show I cannot recommend
their podcasts and his but Joe's podcast
and Jimmy doors YouTube show highly
enough and you don't always have to [ __ ]
and agree with them but I'll tell you
right now I'm gonna tell you something
right now if you [ __ ] watch and see
and then if you watching Fox News and
[ __ ] I mean that's you know those people
okay I'm gonna you know no offense to
other comedians but they're definitely
more well-spoken than a lot of us but
you know I'm just saying there is a
whole you know just look at how they
read the ads on those channels and then
you know exactly like they did their dip
they're stuck between the lines man
I don't know I'm talking about um a [ __ ]
that reminded me of something I just
forgot it what the hell was it something
I wanted to talk about not news not
being between the lines Wow [ __ ] it's
over um so anyways I am going to one of
my favorite things I don't let if I
don't have any favorite things in
Mississippi yet cuz I've only been there
one time two times one time I was
driving up to the airport after I
watched the Patriots beat the Rams in
the Super Bowl and I just couldn't get a
flight into [ __ ]
so we flew in and out of [ __ ] what is
it Baton Rouge Mississippi I'm kidding
Jackson Jackson Mississippi and then I
did a gig there a few years ago so I
don't know a lot about it but Alabama
Alabama I'll take some what I love about
mmm I love the first of all the [ __ ]
I'm going to the Alabama game by the way
on Saturday it's an afternoon game
against mighty mighty Fresno State they
could surprise some people so I'm gonna
go there I'm not gonna be a [ __ ] and
root against Alabama
I really don't hate the Crimson Tide
it's just that they are the [ __ ] the
Yankees or the Patriots so you know
they're the ones that always [ __ ] you
know a winnin right so well Yankees you
know they they want enough even though
they haven't won since 2009 there's
still the [ __ ] Yankees sitting on 27
you know what I mean
I just couldn't become a college fan and
jump on that bandwagon like if I was
watching the NFL I would [ __ ] root
against the Patriots - that's what you
do if you just what you do it's what you
do you don't just jump on the [ __ ]
big bandwagon like Roger Clemens when he
joined the Yankees after they'd already
won [ __ ] three I would say yeah yeah
that's that so that's why I've root
against them so when I go there I'm not
gonna be a [ __ ] I'm gonna root for
Alabama but there's a major part of me
that wants to bet Fresno State and just
start the game up like you know it's 57
to nothing but you know what it is Nick
Saban has an intensity slash anger slash
inability I'm telling you to drown a
puppy that I I just know that even his
second string it's just gonna keep you
know running up the points because they
don't want to deal with it in practice
you know that they didn't score another
[ __ ] 30 points against Fresno's number
one I don't know anything about Fresno
State I'm not trying to disrespect
Fresno okay
now if you like me and you watch any
sort of basic cable stuff about gangs or
prisons or anything they always it's you
know the second they start one of those
shows you can literally turn over an
hourglass of sand and it's not going to
make it halfway through before they end
up in Fresno and then there's always
that guy you know with the bandanna all
the way up to under his eyes a bandana
on his head and then the dark sunglasses
and they have his voice altered names
like no Fresno but to cap your area you
can't understand a word they're saying
right this morning not because my area
grew cold so I'm not trying to [ __ ] with
Fresno
all right everybody knows that [ __ ]
stretch between LA and San Francisco you
don't know what the [ __ ] goes on out
there Charlie Manson lives somewhere up
there all right there's a nice National
Park there's a bunch of people growing
food but other than that you know I
don't know what goes on other than it's
really hot and a lot of people group
airports well I don't have any fun I'm
not trying to [ __ ] [ __ ] on Fresno
okay I'm just a priest pasty freckled
guy trying to go to a football game so
I'm working with Del Rey and [ __ ] Joe
bartnik the Rose Bowl tailgate legend
and we're doing a gig some casino and
miss ship and then we're in Alabama and
when I go to Alabama I got places I like
to eat every time I go there first time
I went there a fan came remember I found
out about go there but I'm sorry q star
stands for smartass Wilson's I always go
there they have a mayonnaise-based
barbecue sauce
swear to God it's white you're like
there's no way that's gonna taste good
you eat it you like Jesus [ __ ]
delicious Jesus Christ is that delicious
so that's a good time I'm actually
thinking of coming back again next year
I'm gonna do a quick gig here and then I
think I'm gonna come back next year do a
little bit of a bigger show and next
year I'm gonna go to Talladega I went to
Daytona 500 I'm gonna go Talladega
next I got to go to that man I used to
always watch that hair Gannon and ask
old man at Carl cale yarborough [ __ ]
what's his fade Rusty Wallace Darrell
Waltrip who else was [ __ ] running
back then Richard Petty was one now I
told you that used to buy all the
[ __ ] model cars I'd build them and
put the stickers on him and [ __ ] I just
always skip the engine because I just
wanted to get to the [ __ ] car part
and I wouldn't let it dry and I wouldn't
let the paint dry I was just too [ __ ]
they always came out like [ __ ] there was
glue all over the place because I was
just too impatient you know I wish I
could buy one of those models again and
actually just take the time to see if I
could do it right like the people who
really did it right they would paint all
the parts before they even took it off
that plastic grid and they would let it
dry for like a day and then they would
just slowly put the whole [ __ ] thing
together and it was a [ __ ] work of
that I would never do that
I was all you know you know was the
worst was when you remember the decals
and you'd soak them in the warm water
then they'd all start coming off and you
were like [ __ ] and they would roll up
and you they'd all look like [ __ ] they'd
be put on like an angle you know then
even he had like the older guys writing
they had a little thing at like pair of
tweezers
all right they'd have a pair of tweezers
and their little [ __ ] you know
jeweler glasses on they'd put it on it
would look unbelievable and I always
wish i had the patience to do that and I
don't and that's why stand-up comedy has
been the only thing that I was ever good
at was because it is just going up there
and just [ __ ] letting you a DD go and
I kind of learned something this week
within a frustrating way trying to learn
drums and it's just like dude you have
to [ __ ] sit down and if you want to
learn something you have to take a big
breath you have to relax and you have to
start really slow and I've known this
for [ __ ] years I've seen everybody
talk about it some of the most monster
players ever talk about how slow they
start a new idea but the whole thing is
you know with all this information on
the internet you could be like well what
BPMS is this song
it's 115 and then you're just thinking
I'm gonna get a defeat and so you start
playing it like 95 when you should be
like 65 so that's my new [ __ ] I gotta
[ __ ] relax I got a pic like one or
two things and just stick with that for
a while just like how you would with the
model right just leave those pieces on
there paint the [ __ ] thing and walk
away just let it dry so anyways I know
I'm a [ __ ] mess here I'm all over I'm
all over the goddamn map 22 minutes of
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] all right we got
six reads here people you know these
[ __ ] reads like these these
advertisers is becoming like a
special-forces you know or a [ __ ]
some sort of military operation here
it's like you know most all right
private Pyle infantry you made it
alright draftkings everybody oh is this
the perfect read for tonight at what
fantasy football season is finally
[ __ ] here and there's no better way
to to get closer to the game you love
with draft kings one-week fantasy
[ __ ] football draft kings is hosting
a 100,000 dollar 50 grand after taxes
contest this Sunday that is totally free
free Brady right enter and if you draft
the perfect lineup you can win 1 billion
dollars in other words the odds that
you're doing that is [ __ ] you know I
don't know what it's pretty [ __ ]
difficult it's the odds of them have
actually taken your junk and making it
into a perfect [ __ ] you know we're not
there yet ok but it doesn't stop these
brave [ __ ] people from still trying
with draft Kingston
there are many ways to play choose
between public contexts with big cash
prizes or private context tests where
you can compete against a group of your
friends draftkings also has a beginner
and casual contact contests where you
can where you'll play against people I
have to get glasses
well you'll play against people of a
similar skill level everybody the best
part is you get to draft a new team each
week without any commitment where is
this going nowhere [ __ ] so to get
draftkings.com now and use promo code
burr use promo code bar to play in the
draftkings free contest with $100,000 in
total prizes this Sunday and if you
draft the perfect lineup you can win 1
billion dollars 1 billion dollars do you
realize that what that is do you have on
that that's that's enough to buy like I
don't know I would say like 706 million
dollar man's you could make 700 Steve
Austin's and still have some money left
over to put on a gift certificate use my
promo code burr to play for free this
Sunday that's promo code burr bu are are
at draft kings.com eligibility
restrictions apply see draft kings.com
for details
eligibility restriction that means their
own employees probably can't play I
would think alright oh [ __ ] look who's
back looking good doesn't count the cost
of fortune Club is revolutionizing the
way men shop at 5 oh geez I've never
found a thing that says their name more
than these people they found a way to
make great-looking clothes
affordable for everyone who also
understands that your time is extremely
valuable
why wasted at the mall or wandering
around in the stores each month they
send you a curated but everybody cure
AIDS now curated box of 2 to 3 items
that are hand-picked from the finest
vine of shirk trees to match the current
season in your style what's their name
again
partners with cutting-edge designers and
brands so you'll get the same quality as
top designer clothes for way less
they've been helping men with fashion
for over 15 years and shipped to over
$100,000 100,000 men every month Chris
Paul in mock Wahlberg who's five and
five faux is featured in GQ vice and
InStyle among other publications they
know what they're doing so if you don't
that's okay why because Oh club will
help you build your wardrobe one month
at a time Jesus Christ how many more
times they're gonna say their name you
get on Attorney dollars worth of clothes
for just $60 a month you can pause or
cancel anytime no commitments I said no
and as a club member FIFO Club baby
remember you'll also receive up to 50%
off items in their online shop and
access to exclusive Members Only not the
jacket items free shipping and sighs
exchanges go too fast
Oh
dot-com right now an enter promo code
Burt and they'll give you 50% off your
first month's package plus a free pair
of sunglasses everything is so much
crisper and clearer that's 50% off your
first package at 5fo Club spelled F
isn't fab I as an Ave ve fo fo you are
the numbers 5 for club.com CL you be
calm promo code bar 5 fo club.com promo
code Burt
that's it alright I'll lift everybody oh
Jesus Christ look who's back it's lift
you know what lift knows they know that
their drivers are what keeps them moving
well that's what the [ __ ] you do do you
know what coke knows if you're thirsty
so they do everything they could do to
make sure their drivers are happy on
every trip lift is the ride-sharing
company that believes in treating its
people better lifts believes that being
a
share a driver should be fun if you're
having a good time
so are there passengers if you're
choosing a ride-sharing company to drive
for go with the company that treats you
better lift lift was the first to offer
in-app tipping when you drive for lyft
you keep 100% of the tips drivers get
paid over 200 million dollars in tips
since the feature was introduced Express
pay lets drivers get paid almost
instantly instead of four weeks it has
even taken the guesswork out of pickups
the new amp amp device uses isn't that
app color coding to help passengers find
their drivers you can earn hundreds of
dollars a week plus tips want to earn
more money drive more it's never been
easy to give yourself a raise it's a
simple formula happy drivers mean happy
passengers maybe that's why 9 out of 10
lit riders get a perfect five-star
rating so join the ride-sharing company
that believes in treating its people
better go to left
dot-com slash birt'day and you'll get a
$500 new driver bonus that's list.com /
berlin calm / burn limited time only
terms apply is that the new thing you
say you [ __ ] name 50 time oh oh this
is the classic this is the stairway to
heaven of my advertising look who's back
it's old zip talk about the challenge of
finding great talent and/or the
importance of finding great talent to a
successful business I'll tell you right
now finding Talent is easy but to find
great chalice really hard especially if
you want to be successful in business
Bill Byrne I approve this message
how zip is different with zip recruit
hakuna you can post your job to 100 plus
job sites with just one click it's so
easy then they're powerful technology
wait officially matches the right people
to your job better than anyone else
that's why is it it's different
unlike other job sites sip
group doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it's its finds it finds them
in fact 80% of employees who post a
gentleman's if group get a quality
candidate through the site within one
day no more juggling emails or calls to
your [ __ ] office simply screen and
rate and manage candidates in wall at
one place with zipper cruises
easy-to-use dashboard find out today why
is it has been used by up businesses of
all sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates and immediate results and
right now my listeners plus any other
[ __ ] podcast they advertise on can
post jobs unzip recruited for free
that's right free just go to zip
recruiter calm cyber that zip recruiter
calm slash bro one more time to try to
try it for free go to zip comm slash
burp all right up side up side comm boy
you turn me inside out and go [ __ ]
yourself there's a better way for you to
buy business travel it's called up side
damn no up side dot-com you turn me
somebody finally told me how to sing
that every time you buy a trip on upside
upside comm get turn to me you'll save
your company a ton of money and they
give you an Amazon gift card worth
hundreds of dollars upsides able to do
this because they bundle your flights
and hotels together for one low price
bundling prices saves money it's like
having a threesome
it saves condom wait is that's still
safe if you're a frequent business
traveler your company saves a ton of
money and you could get thousands a year
in gift cards just for buying your air
and hotel together at UPS addcom plus
you'll still get all your miles if
you're shopping for a business travel
you'd be crazy not to check out upside
comm it takes just three minutes to see
how much you can save by buying your
flights and hotels together for one low
price and right now when you use my name
bar you're guaranteed to get at least a
$100 Amazon giftcard your first trip
that's my name Barbie you are are to get
at least a $100 Amazon gift card for
free save big on travel and get a big
gift card every trip evidently I love
upside calm boy you turn me upside calm
you're turning me minimum purchase for
quiet C sight for complete details hey
you know when I watch the other day I
watched an episode of TJ [ __ ] hooker
the I will tell you this right now the
funniest running you will ever see in
your life by William Shatner and his
[ __ ] partner all they do is they
they're constantly have like a [ __ ]
wide shot and they show TJ Hooker runnin
like he runs for like six seconds every
shot it's like why I would you know what
it is is they had they had to [ __ ] do
an hour's 22 or I figure out a full
season was back then they're like 22
episodes of an hour-long show that's 22
hours of television well actually with
the with the commercials eight minutes
per half-hour 44 minutes they iterate 44
minutes a [ __ ] [ __ ] times 22 I mean
it's it's like well we came up short
again well just have William Shatner run
a little longer kid TJ Hooker like run
half the length of a football field
before he catches up to somebody a third
of his [ __ ] age I saw the one I gotta
get this actress name he was one of he
was one of my one of my favorite actors
when I was growing up he was in colors
he was a Latino dude he got hit by a
drunk driver unfortunately was like 37
to 30 38 years old hang on I gotta get
this guy's name uh let's see colors IMDB
I didn't know Don Cheadle was in that
movie I gotta watch that again that'd be
one of his earliest ones I am on
nightmare walkin
it's something silver I believe Trinidad
Silva
so he was in this episode of this
episode of TJ Hooker and it was [ __ ]
hilarious because all of a sudden TJ
Hooker when he's talking to him would
throwing some [ __ ] Latino words and
it was only like [ __ ] that like gay let
white people know like que pasa [ __ ]
agua he said at one point well maybe if
you stop acting like a polo like he
threw in like chicken and it's just like
yeah that's cuz the writing staff
ordered El Pollo Loco that day but
Trinidad Silva I believe he was in the
jerk I think he was in it well you know
when I look up his [ __ ] this guy was
amazing he was in Hill Street Blues he
was in the jerk yeah he actually died
during the filming of underrated movie
by Weird Al Yankovic called UHF I was in
colors yet Hill Street Blues stir-crazy
he had such shame he died so young yeah
he was on Barney Miller I mean that this
guy Lou Grant the white shadow the jerk
this guy's IMDB page Beretta you know
granted you played played a perp in all
of those [ __ ] things he's probably
fixing games on the white shadow that's
the way it was back then
and this guy somehow got through it and
opened the doors for a bunch of other
people I hadn't seen him in a while it's
great to see him Trinidad Silva look him
up 1915 in 1988 unfortunately he was uh
he was only 38 years old Jesus Christ
phenomenal actor them all right
LegalZoom last one here LegalZoom when
you run your own business when you know
that time equals money it's not just an
old saying it's a fact so why a why
waste your valuable time dealing with an
issue that LegalZoom can help you with
I'm doing this because I'm going to
Mississippi at Alabama this weekend you
may already know put your hands in the
air and feel the Spirit of Jesus that
over two million people have used
LegalZoom to start their business but
LegalZoom services don't end there
there's a kingdom waiting for you after
you get their [ __ ] website running a
business comes with taxes contracts
hiring employees and the devil basically
a lot of fine print
and we all know that the Devils in the
details sorry
that's why legal don't built a network
of independent attorneys licensed in all
50 states
not in Puerto Rico not in our
territories just the 50 states they
could provide the advice you need to get
through the daily grind of running your
business by the way everybody in Puerto
Rico hope you make it through this storm
good lord
good lord man rogon scared the [ __ ] out
of me and I live in [ __ ] la can't
imagine what poor people are doing out
there and you don't have to worry about
billable hours since LegalZoom isn't a
law firm instead you can count on
upfront pricing and clarity call to
action invest your time and money and
growing your business and let legals
they'll help you out with legal stuff
for special savings b for special
savings be sure to enter promo code
Burpee URR and the referral box at
checkout that's promo code bar for
special savings only at legalzoom.com
high legalzoom.com
all right I think that's the podcast for
this week I'm gonna go play some drums
and he very relaxed actually I'm not I
got to go write an episode episode 309
of of season three of f is for family
we're actually this week we're working
on Episode seven so you not in the
business the reason why it's called 309
and 3 means season 3 I never knew what
that meant I finally figured it out
after three seasons I remember last year
it's like we're working on 204 and I'd
be sitting in the back of the room like
we're not on the 200th 4th episode but I
knew that sounded stupid so I finally
just I finally just asked you know then
I felt it I felt all the writers looking
at me like why is this hacky comedian in
this [ __ ] room you know and it hurts
no I'm kidding my work with great people
in case any of them are listening and if
you're the one person in the writers
from listening you're my favorite writer
in the world so I'm write in the episode
309 that's why I have to do today I just
do like I do two scenes a day and then I
get through the script and then I I do
like three or four passes I didn't do
that last year but this year I'm going
to do it and then I bring it in and then
everybody just guts the thing and maybe
like three jokes make it but you know
it's all about making
template and that's the game that
everybody [ __ ] place all right so
that's the podcast
let's go pass doctor [ __ ] year off
right who's gonna step into Edelman
shoes before he comes back for the
wonderful playoff run ok I hope he
doesn't come back too soon you know do
you know why Edelman got hurt that was
the curse of the nude ESPN magazine
issue you don't I mean I I can't
remember the last time I left harder
than watching him jump through the air
catch a ball and have it over his junk
is he flew through the air that was one
of the funniest [ __ ] things I've ever
seen I just don't understand how a woman
I don't know maybe I guess whatever I
just don't understand how any level that
is anything other than [ __ ] hilarious
naked men are for that we're just funny
I used to pit my axe a naked man is one
of two things it's either funny or scary
depending on what's happening like if
you're at a game and a naked guy runs
across the [ __ ] field I mean you're
[ __ ] on the ground laughing however
if you're walking home late at night and
a naked guy jumps out of bush like yeah
that's the scariest [ __ ] thing you'll
ever see
right I'd rather see a [ __ ]
rattlesnake you know I would rather see
that I'm terrified of [ __ ] snakes ok
then to have some [ __ ] naked guy jump
out of a [ __ ] bush
I probably shouldn't just given out that
information alright anyways dude let's
troll them anyways alright that's the
the podcast for this Thursday have a
great weekend you [ __ ] enjoy the
football game tonight the college
football this weekend may be tuned into
Alabama Fresno State I will be there I
will be there and thank you everybody in
Mississippi and Alabama for buying a
tickets I'm gonna come out there with my
Yankee [ __ ] and telling you guys
once again why you lost that war alright
enjoy the music here and we're gonna
have another half-hour stuff from a
classic podcast from a Thursday gone by
in a year that already happened or
possibly earlier this year I don't know
what it is all right that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast for
Monday September 7th 2009 happy Labor
Day happy Labor Day what are you guys
doing today huh with your big bad days
off what are you doing you laying around
you becoming fat [ __ ] what are you
doing you barbecuing we're going over to
Carol's
and we're gonna have a barbecue you want
to come Stephon no I don't I want to
[ __ ] drink
and forget that I married you Carol um
sorry
I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm moving some [ __ ]
around right now um this is the Monday
morning podcast I'm gonna said Cod pass
podcast I'm actually gonna try to do
some something different this week
because it's such a special [ __ ]
holiday cuz it is Labor Day why does the
word sorry I always have to do a tribute
to [ __ ] 80s comedy I'm actually
watching a [ __ ] I watched too much
sports this weekend and I just was
watching the end of the Colorado
Colorado State football game and right
after it I tape best damn tough man you
know cuz the game always goes longer
than its allotted so you have to take
the next show listen to this [ __ ]
spaz he goes by the name of the coach
this is the classic example of a scared
guy before a fight and he's trying to
turn that fear into like some sort of
[ __ ] courage but it works this guy
goes by the coach this is hilarious
they're actually showing him right now
he's getting his gloves put on listen to
this maniac
I don't know you're getting here that
but basically he's standing there and he
just goes like it's show time and then
he just snaps it joke ah he just
you got a I'm sorry I don't even know if
this is even gonna translate but I got I
gotta get the rest of this [ __ ] here I
got to get the other thing that he
[ __ ] says here what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this stupid piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
goddamn cable anybody else have this
[ __ ] problem with your cable did I
just delete it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright whatever goddamnit that was
gonna be such a that was like my big
[ __ ] different beginning that I was
just gonna have there and I just ended
up deleting it cuz my [ __ ] cable
sucks yeah what are you gonna do it's a
holiday right I shouldn't even be doing
this
so anyway so the next time they they
they come to him he's screaming some
more so he goes out there and of course
he doesn't had a fight he's flailing or
he's flailing around with this dude and
in the end you know he gets knocked on
his ass and he and he loses so it's the
it's every face achill every time they
show the guy he would say want the first
little thing he would say quietly and
then he would just completely flip out I
can't [ __ ] believe I got I deleted
that what an [ __ ]
so whatever the guy ends up losing in
the end of the fight he goes uh he goes
I'm ready for some more I ain't even
bleeding yet and then he just snapped I
ain't buying it ah [ __ ] I don't know
what cuts sport that guy coaches but if
I was playing on his team I would run
through a [ __ ] wall for that guy you
know I don't know all the pens depends
on your personality you know I like
maniacs like that god damn it I can't
believe that [ __ ] I knew that was gonna
happen
I knew it was gonna happen you know
what's the worst it was not all I'd be
bad enough if I had to try and rewind it
and get back to where the hell it was
but then then I it comes up with the
delete thing and I accidentally deleted
it I'm sorry everybody
yeah [ __ ] where the hell do you go from
here um it's Labor Day well what exactly
are you supposed to do on Labor Day am I
supposed to observe something for all
the people who died at work do they have
a little parade do you guys like parades
those little pathetic things with the
mediocrity talented people of your town
marched down your [ __ ] Street isn't
that the worst when you come from a
small town it's just a numbers game I
mean how many truly [ __ ] talented
people can there be but somehow they
still have to put together a band you
know some chick with braces playing a
[ __ ] flute marching down the street
and then they always end it with like a
fire engine just trying to drown out
your bad local band or everybody's
singing in monotone a bunch of dentists
and accountants sitting there with their
[ __ ] weird-ass looking kids do they
do that today is that what you're
supposed to do am I supposed to be
dressed up like it's the revolutionary
war re-enacted something I got to be
honest with you Labor Day feels like
every other [ __ ] day to me because
I'm a comedian and I'm always sitting in
my underwear at [ __ ] 12:00 noon all
right that's why I do this do you think
I want to make you [ __ ] people laugh
I don't I don't I just remember when I
was 14 sitting in my underwear eating
toast one day on a Saturday morning and
I was thinking wouldn't be [ __ ] great
if I could do this every day you know
wake up watch cartoons wrestle with my
[ __ ] dog you know and just have
absolutely no responsibility whatsoever
and I got to tell you something I made
that dream come true never get worried
when you die God's just gonna be looking
at the video your life you know just
looking at it then kind of glancing over
you and just just shaking his head
really you get one shot at this and this
is this is what you did do you realize
that you spent over 98 thousand hours of
your life in your underwear and I'm not
even counting when you were [ __ ]
sleeping oh speaking of that the other
day I'm still on I'm still sorry you
just walked by laughing at me like I'm
an idiot I I'm still on European time
today was the first day actually got up
at nine o'clock I've basically I have
been when I was over in Sweden how did
you feel about that when I was over in
Sweden last week Cleo
what are you doing you stop walking
around like a creep
my dog is like most big dogs there she's
apt she doesn't realize how big she is
and so she's but she's not afraid of a
lot of things you know she's not afraid
of other dogs but hardwood floors scare
the [ __ ] out of her so she's so worried
that she's gonna be slipping she walks
like really slowly and daintily all
around the apartment and it looks like
she's gonna like sneak up on you
something that's right just lay down all
right a teacher I had a howl oh you guys
want to see something [ __ ] adorable
do you want to see you want to see
something that will make you actually
believe again in whatever the [ __ ] you
stop believing and go on YouTube in
search boxer bo x ER and baby and
there's a little baby playing with a
boxer and I'm telling you it's it's it's
one of the most adorable things you'll
ever see you know there would be less
violence in the world if everybody
watched this video actually that's not
true
everyone would watch the video and then
the second somebody next to you went oh
you rage would come back and you'd want
to just [ __ ] blast him in the face
but whatever I digress let me get back
to what I was talking about I'm so
anyways so I have been when I was over
in speed and yeah I was up all night and
and then I would sleep all day like that
awful heavy metal song by that band
slaughter and right that that's when you
knew it was over everybody said it was
over when [ __ ] Nirvana came out no it
wasn't it was over when slaughter came
out slaughter slaughtered the rest of
hair metal that awful guy's voice know
what isn't right it isn't it's [ __ ]
terrible
um anyways I'm plowing ahead here so I
finally got used to the time over in 3
and then I came back to the states here
and now I'm on Sweden time so basically
I have been up every [ __ ] night
watching old football clips and whatnot
on on the internet and I call you guys
all sent me emails going I swear to God
I don't work for the NFL man just tell
me where I can see them where do you see
all the videos where is the main site
where everybody watches videos that's
where the [ __ ] they are okay
it rhymes with Moo Lube anyways so
that's what I've been doing late at
night I've been watching these [ __ ]
videos and what am I trying to say here
I don't know what happened so yeah so I
fall asleep at about 6:00 6:30 in the
morning I sleep until 1:00 in the
afternoon that's what has been happening
to me I feel like a [ __ ] drug addict
right so evidently yesterday I was
passed out and for some reason I was in
the nude all right go ahead visualize
that one facedown in the [ __ ] nude
and my girlfriend took a picture of me
because she thought it was funny
and I saw it and I I don't know I I
never really had a look I never thought
it was a good-looking guy but I thought
it was alright I saw myself laying there
butt ass naked and I got a met dude I
look like a [ __ ] cadaver that was the
worst part it's not that I looked out of
shape I'm in decent shape I just look
like somebody just said fish me out of a
river that's the only way I could
describe it the only thing missing was
Bill Curtis his voice just narrating I'm
Bill Curtis a pasty freckly man was
fished out of [ __ ] River the other
day this sleepy little town with there
with the fog was gonna say Memorial Day
what the [ __ ] is it Labor Labor Day
parade hey stupid [ __ ] with braces
playing a flute it looks perfect and
toxic on me right now go and you do not
sound like Bill Curtis whatever I
[ __ ] looked I was dead so I deleted
the picture and then my girlfriend felt
bad I thought it was cute I didn't want
to make you self-conscious
I thought it was cute it wasn't cute no
one should see what they look like
facedown naked I can't shake the image I
hope you guys aren't having your [ __ ]
your traditional Labor Day breakfast
well not while you're visualizing that
Jesus Christ look at that rosetta stone
remember I was gonna learn how to speak
Spanish okay it when you do that when
you're like I'm gonna learn I do this
[ __ ] and you and you buy something and
you just stick it on your bookshelf and
it's just sitting there mocking your
laziness for the next nine months I got
that for Christmas last year and I
cannot [ __ ] say anything in Spanish
you don't really gonna do I'm gonna go
down to Home Depot and I'm gonna find
one of those Mexican dudes who are
always asking me if they can [ __ ]
rewire my entire apartment for [ __ ]
three dollars because of the hardy
hardest-working [ __ ] people on the
planet
I'm just look dude why don't I just give
you 20 bucks and teach you and you just
teach me how to speak Spanish is that
okay and then of course they'd be like I
know I'd I don't know I don't know what
well I I know I want I want you to teach
me teach me how to speak I'd I don't
know like you I don't know what you're
saying
we just sit there for [ __ ] an hour
and then after a while my forehead would
be sunburned and I would just give up
that's probably what happened who knows
maybe I would actually make a friend
down there and maybe he was really good
in an instrument he was slightly
[ __ ] and then I would draw that
talent out and then someday Freddie
Prinze jr. would have a comeback playing
that dude and we can make a little
oscar-winning movie maybe that could
happen
all right let's plow ahead let's let's
get let's let's actually be smart this
week and rather than waiting until 50
minutes into this podcast to hype what
the [ __ ] I have to hype why don't I hype
what I have to hype right [ __ ] now
okay well I'm gonna do that of course
the second I say it my [ __ ] computer
shuts down all right hang on a second
all right
this week I am going to be in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania at the helium
comedy club September 10th 11th and 12th
for the love of God please come out to
that show please show up and I got a
brand new hour at least since the last
time I've been
because I haven't been there like a year
and a half and that's plenty of time for
me to come up with some new [ __ ] so
please come down there I'm actually
gonna try to go to a Phillies game check
out that new stadium and what else am I
gonna do there I think that's it I think
that's it you know what somebody
actually sent me an email
you know because last week I was telling
you guys about how you can watch those
Super Bowls Cleo would you just take a
confidence step in the apartment Jesus
Christ you would think there were land
mines under the floor the dog has never
fallen down that's the funny thing I
could see if she fell down the first day
she was here and then she'd have this
little my god oh my god
she's never falling down I know she's
pathetic to see a scared pit bull isn't
it anyway so this guy actually told me
about a if you're into hockey hockey I
don't know I just set it that way for
into hockey there's actually a [ __ ]
website if I can find it where I was
watching the 1974 Stanley Cup finals
like Game six I'd never seen it and I
was watching the Bruins versus the
Flyers of course the Flyers probably win
that [ __ ] game because I know they
won the series and you have to go to
this is it right here this is for the
sports fans out there it's H F boards
Beal ard Escom slash actually you know
what just go to that H boards calm and
just go to that and just start searching
for some games and they have all the
original games in their entirety and if
you were a big sports fan like I am it's
great to watch those because you can
watch how the game has changed and all
that type of stuff I got to be honest
man I had like the greatest [ __ ]
weekend ever where you know just because
college football started and I don't
happen like two two years ago I became a
college football [ __ ] maniac and I
absolutely loved it and I was actually
once again sleeping until noon which is
[ __ ] like three o'clock East Coast
time so I missed like most of the first
games I think I think it was like miss
like the first three quarters of the
first game so I wake up my girl actually
gives she would have made some breakfast
she actually brings it in to me I have
breakfast in bed and I walk into the
living room after I eat it she just made
me breakfast
in bed people okay and I [ __ ] and she
goes in to watch one of her reality
shows and I woke up and after I ate the
breakfast I realized that I was missing
all these college games so I just
stumbled into the living room because
when you're my age you stumble for the
first hour when you wake up because for
some reason your Achilles shrink up to
your [ __ ] the bottom of your ass and
your legs don't work right right so I
stumbled in here and I just took the
remote from our usually I say honey
demon would you mind if I just kind of I
didn't I just [ __ ] walked in and I
put on the USC game and she rightfully
just looked down at the floor like
really I just made you [ __ ] steak and
eggs and you [ __ ] just come wandering
in here and then she just sort of walked
out and then I had to do that pathetic
you know when you want to apologize for
something you just did but you want to
continue doing the thing that you that
you're apologizing for
so rather than hitting pause I kept
watching the game like yelling out the
side of my mouth as she was walking away
oh I'm sorry honey I I just continue to
watch the game and she gave me the
silent treatment for the next four hours
which actually worked out good I think I
watched like 12 football games this
weekend I don't know why anybody gets
the [ __ ] NFL package you don't need
it you can get all the college games you
want for free and the kids are young
they haven't blown out their knees
they're [ __ ] maniacs nobody's holding
out I don't know I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm saying you know it's getting
hot in here cuz I have to close my
goddamn windows cuz I curse too much
when I do this you know what I actually
I have some more audio here let me take
actually a sip of water like I'm Frank
Sinatra in between [ __ ] songs here
alright um
yep hear him say that he makes a joke
back then when it was funny that you
were drinking booze on stage I actually
found another record if you guys are
actually big fans of my podcast you know
what sucks about this [ __ ] is I have to
literally move my mixer and everything
else listen to it hit the floor
see then hear that there we go goddamn
these [ __ ] wires I've been slowly but
surely and that's how you never say I've
been slowly you always have to say but
surely you always say that they think
they go together you know sick and tired
slowly but surely
suck my dick lick my balls you know it
all goes together alright here we go
I've been basically buying my dad's
record collection one album at a time
and this is one of the weirdest [ __ ]
albums my dad had as a kid because I was
a kid and I didn't know any better I
loved it listen to this [ __ ] this is
basically the original like you know
when you watch Austin Powers and they're
kind of mocking the weird music of the
60s this is basically why this is a
called persuasive percussion 1966 and in
defense of the orchestra I think that
they were trying to demonstrate as many
instruments as they possibly could
isolated how good they sound and the
newfound HiFi stereo so here we go
listen to this [ __ ] any day now come the
horns how is that the [ __ ] of what you
know a lot of people if they say if
they'd go back in a time machine that
they would go back and try and stop
Hitler I wouldn't I go back to this
[ __ ] recording session because I just
want to see the looks on people's faces
when they play that kind of music I
always picture Barney rubbles face you
know when he was playing the drums in
that one Fred Flintstone episode we got
Barney Rubble looking for trouble and he
had like his eyes were all squinted like
that's I just picture all these guys and
like [ __ ] those turtlenecks with with
the the piece I remember how Buddy Rich
was was dressing and like the the early
70s when he was trying to act like he
was still gonna stay relevant with these
new hip kooky kids but he was still
playing big band music and he would come
out
with like these plaid Johnny Carson
[ __ ] Haggar slacks a knitted
turtleneck and then he on the outside of
the turtleneck a little precursor to
Eddie Murphy's pinkie ring on the
outside of his glove he would have his
and he'd have his necklace outside the
turtleneck with with a peace sign and it
was all in like silver I don't know and
he let his hair grow a little long and
hear that awful [ __ ] to pay you know
but he still was [ __ ] fantastic all
right was that worth the trip all the
way over to my HiFi stereo do you guys
have a hi-fi huh all right sorry about
that I'm a [ __ ] nerd so that's
basically I did all this weekend I
listen to bad records and I was
listening to and watching all these
football games and I got to admit you
got to watch these old football games
because it is such [ __ ] nowadays the
way they don't like these [ __ ] wide
receivers can they can do whatever they
want you can't even cover the [ __ ]
receivers huh any Georgia Bulldog fans
out there how bad did you guys get
[ __ ] on that call I'm not saying that
you would have won the game but that was
definitely a pivotal [ __ ] moment this
guy is going over the middle the ball is
thrown high and the defect of the
defensive back lays him out that's
football
and then like unnecessary yay and Yankee
Gary Webb that roughness was unnecessary
who's [ __ ] pathetic I mean
unnecessary I'm doing my [ __ ] job if
you want to see how far football is
changed go out [ __ ] it who gives a [ __ ]
go onto YouTube and just [ __ ] Search
Search 1978 AFC Championship game
Steelers vs. the Houston Oilers and
watch part four go all the way to the
end you gonna see Mike barber goes over
the middle Dan Pastorini
the [ __ ] douchebag throws it like
nine feet over his head but Mike Mike
barber is a gamer right so he goes up
for the thing Mike Wagner comes in
doesn't even look at the ball and just
[ __ ] goes as low as he possibly can
hits Mike barber right on his goddamn
knees you ever see a guy on YouTube you
ever watch a guy who like slam into a
fence doing 80 miles an hour on a
[ __ ] motorcycle and that way you
you just launched it's like you're
standing up in the air but you're doing
flips head-over-heels that's what he did
he flip flipped around like twice landed
on this astroturf and he's holding his
[ __ ] knee and flipping out and you
know he's on the ground for like five
minutes when he gets up he's pointing
Mike Mike Wagner you [ __ ]
you cheap [ __ ] screaming all
this stuff and the announcers in the
booth they're just sitting there going
like well you know Mike wasn't looking
at the ball so I mean I know I'm mr.
barbers really he's really annoyed but I
mean why he was just doing his job it's
just doing his job you know there was no
unnecessary roughness
actually there was back then but you
actually had to do something that was
unnecessary now you're doing the
necessary [ __ ] it is to cover a [ __ ]
receiver and they go it's unnecessary
that's why one of the biggest [ __ ]
records ever broken was Dan Marino's
touchdown record by Peyton Manning
remember that year when he cried because
the [ __ ] Patriots the players
actually covered his [ __ ] receivers
you know we're trying too hard and then
next thing you know you can't even touch
these [ __ ] guys and he breaks Dan
Marino's record a marina or to throw 90
touchdowns if you couldn't touch Clayton
and duper alright that's it I'm done I'm
done with the sports this week cuz I
know people like I don't watch sports
anyway when you talk about sports I get
bored well you know something listen to
another [ __ ] podcast alright you're
whiny [ __ ] go enjoy your [ __ ] labor
day on somebody else's podcast how do
you like that look at me getting all
tough
alright you don't you guys want to UM oh
wait real quick my team is LSU I think
I'm gonna go with LSU this year there's
some about that Les Miles I just like
the guy fourth and 12 two minutes into
the game and he [ __ ] goes for it this
is like a direct quote for him they go
les why do you always go for it on
fourth down and he says well you know
what when you have playmakers on your
team you have an obligation to turn them
loose that might be one of the greatest
quotes ever I love this southern [ __ ]
turn em loose
you got playmakers on your team buddy
okay you follow me you have an
obligation turning loose just turn them
dogs loose just see what to come up with
go out there dig up the [ __ ] first
down
greatest [ __ ] fake field goal of all
time LSU look that up LSU fake field
goal it's the smoothest [ __ ] you're ever
gonna see just flips it right over his
goddamn shoulder I was [ __ ] it was a
thing of beauty
alright here's some YouTube videos for
you guys if you're new to my podcast
this is what I do every week I asked
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] in my apartment and
people send me in these YouTube videos
already gave you the box or baby one and
the LSU fake field goal and this is just
a creepy one it's really quick but it's
really creepy look up animal recording
fail animal recording fail it's somebody
filming an anaconda or some big-ass
[ __ ] snake and evidently this snake
was not ready for its close-up okay
we'll just leave it at that and don't
make it jump it'll [ __ ] make you jump
alright this is gonna be a quick podcast
I'm already to the questions you know
I'm only 24 minutes in you know what
this feels like this feels like when I'm
[ __ ] bombing on stage and I know a
lot of you guys out there are not
comedians sure we all aren't and
basically what happens is when you're
having a great set all right say you're
slated to do 50 minutes ok somebody
comes back and they say hey kid
can you give me 50 minutes can you go
out there and give it to college track
right you [ __ ] go out there and you
start killing and if you're killing and
if you're totally on what ends up
happening is you do 50 minutes and you
feel like you only did half your act you
know but on nights when you're bombing
you're about two jokes away from your
closing bit and you look down at your
watching you're about 12 minutes into
your set and that's when the dry mouth
sets in and you're like okay yeah so
what do you do for a living oh yeah
here's my cute little jokes about
[ __ ] plumbers you know that's the
worst I have to tell you about to sell
my first headlining gigs this is
basically how I became a headliner was
first year I had to write the material
alright and I gotten up to I knew I had
45 minutes but I had never done 45
minutes and when you headline are going
last or whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it on
show as a headliner you have to do at
least 45 minutes that's how it works
okay I don't know where the [ __ ] you
guys are from where I'm from that's how
it [ __ ] works you got to do 45
minutes so I've been doing stand-up for
about three and a half four years so I
had written 45 minutes of material but I
had never done 45 minutes you don't I
mean I was basically at that point I was
I was the feature actor the second guy
so I was doing like anywhere from 20
minutes to 30 minutes at the most
usually feature act does 20 to 25 30 if
you were working with like an old bitter
headliner who's given into the fact that
he's not going to make it or maybe he
just doesn't feel like doing it you know
that's when you work with those guys and
should they just come up to you and I
like I work with this guy one time and
he looks at me and he goes he goes hey
kid [ __ ] he goes huh how much time you
got um I don't know 30 35 and he just
goes do all of it he's like do your
whole [ __ ] act play with the crowd I
don't give a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] do 11
minutes and close the show I've had it
right so anyways yeah so I had written
45 minutes of material and I but I'd
never done it all in a row so I didn't
know how to put it together so when I
moved down to New York you know the only
way to start headlining is at some point
you got to bite the bullet and just tell
somebody that you're a headliner you
don't tell that to a to a good room you
tell it to like you know you have a
rooms you have B rooms you got seeing D
rooms so like the C and D rooms I was
like I just told the guys yeah I'm a
headliner and they're looking at me you
know it's just a kid they like you're a
headliner and I'm like yeah yeah I'm a
headliner you know it's like we trying
to get served when you were underage you
just try to have that look at confidence
don't flinch just give him the money I
would like a vodka Collins yes I would
me and my one whisker on my chin would
like to have some alcohol thank you very
much and the first time I headlined I
remember I went on after this this this
black dude was on in front of me and he
was totally like high-energy to begin
with and that's one of the first things
you learn how to do was a headline is
how to follow somebody if they have high
[ __ ] energy right so this guy's doing
his act
and you know it like you know he's been
doing it for a long time so he just
keeps building with the energy building
and building and building and he ended
his act doing some jokes about like a
prostate exam and by the end he's just
screaming and he's got his [ __ ]
finger my [ __ ] ass is screaming
into this mic killing in this restaurant
and I'm sitting there I'm already
sweating trying to think how the [ __ ] am
I gonna follow that guy and I made the
biggest [ __ ] mistake you can ever do
is when somebody ends and they're on
eleven with the energy the worst [ __ ]
thing that you can do is to go onstage
and start your act at the same energy
that that that guy left off first of all
you're not going to have enough energy
there's no way you can't be on ten for
forty five [ __ ] minutes you're gonna
pass out okay and not only that it's
bizarre to have someone just come out on
stage you know please welcome Bill burr
I sounded like that guy in the tough man
thing you know you gotta get psyched
you gotta get Punk'd I was coming out
with like that kind of energy so I went
up there and eight minutes in screaming
my act I am pouring sweat and I remember
looking down at my watch feeling like I
had done at least 25 minutes and I had
only done like eleven minutes and I was
out of breath out of breath from telling
[ __ ] jokes and I had no I just
remember there was for some reason there
was a big fish tank in this place and I
was trying to riff about the fish tank
and it was a restaurant and like anybody
ordered the fillet of fish cuz I think I
know where they got it yeah it was it
was awful oh just [ __ ] off no you
know what actually got a bad feeling
just even thinking about that [ __ ]
said so if you are competing and you're
listening to this and you're just
starting to headline if you follow
somebody with energy what you actually
want to do is go in the opposite
direction that's what I learned is you
go up there and you just start really
[ __ ] slow and actually kind of eat
your balls for a you know just let
everybody just bring it down everybody
[ __ ] relax
and then once you get him relaxed then
you start to build them up again you
know what I mean it's just like doing
drugs you start coming down but you know
once you go through the floor and you
start feeling depression you take
another drug and you start coming back
up again that's that's where right there
right is you go below the floorboards
that's when I grab you by the back of
your [ __ ] goddamn shirt and I pull
you back up again comedic Lee and then
we then we go back up again but this is
what ended up happening was I would do
my jokes and I could kill for 37 minutes
and for some reason when I said 37
minutes I just wrote it on my ottoman
with my finger I wrote 37 like the
[ __ ] Rain Man I really have a lot of
Rain Man qualities I don't know if
you've noticed that but uh like I can
actually name all everybody who's won
the Superbowl the last 43 years and no I
don't have it in front of me but I can
do it so if you ever see me I'll [ __ ]
rattle them off rattle them off I'll
have my head to the side just like the
[ __ ] Rain Man and they want me to go
back and name all the losers I can
[ __ ] do that and I was actually at
one point wanted to memorize where all
the Super Bowls took place and that's
when right after I had that thought I
kind of caught myself in a mirror I was
just like what are you doing bill what
are you running from
you know because I'm just sitting there
in the mirror going Green Bay Green Bay
Jets Chiefs Colts Cowboys dolphins
dolphins Steeler Steelers yeah Raiders
Cowboys so you can I still do what
Steeler Steelers and then Jim Plunkett
with the [ __ ] Raiders Jill Montana
that was in Pontiac Michigan they beat
the Bengals and they stopped Pete
Johnson right down on the goal line and
then the [ __ ] Redskins who I hated
because I was a huge Cowboy fan
they beat the Dolphins that Fulton
Walker huh took that kickoff back see I
remember all this [ __ ] and the Raiders
kicked the [ __ ] out of the Redskins the
next year and then [ __ ] 49ers beat the
Dolphins remember that Sports
Illustrated what Dan Marino was on the
cover and he was pointing at him like
yeah this is going to be the first one
right with Joe Montana next year was the
Bears which could have been the greatest
[ __ ] Super Bowl ever you know I'm
just going all sports this week I don't
give a [ __ ] just gonna give you guys a
heads up do you remember that the Bears
went 15 and 1 in the regular season okay
and the only team they lost to was the
Dolphins on a Monday night and it was
[ __ ] awesome because the Dolphins
basically defended the 72 dolphins
you know undefeated record by beating
the [ __ ] bears so in the AFC
Championship game that year it was the
Dolphins first the Patriots and we were
playing him in the Orange Bowl and we
had this curse we had we had never won
in the Orange Bowl for like [ __ ] I
don't like 20 goddamn years okay since
like Lyndon Johnson was in office and
the San Diego Chargers played in Los
Angeles okay and then the [ __ ]
dolphin should have beat us and then
they should have gone to the Super Bowl
and then the Bears should have been set
up to [ __ ] avenge their one loss of
the year and then the Dolphins with Dan
Marino and that unbelievable [ __ ]
offense was the only ones that was able
to beat the 46 defense and what [ __ ]
happens
stupid ass Patriots we come in there and
we beat them right and then you know
with squish the fish remember that
squish the fish and everybody in Miami
was just like dolphins or the food guru
minimal hello was some of the gayest
[ __ ] talking ever did during that time
and somebody had made a song in Boston
remember that song by Pete Townsend face
to face
that face to face got to face to face
something like that somebody wrote us
squish the fish to that song squish the
fish got to squeezed it was [ __ ]
horrific but somehow I still actually
watch the game and then the Patriots got
they got raped I believe is the best way
to describe it
by the Bears 46 to 10 then the next year
was the Giants then the Redskins then
49ers 49ers and then was the bills era
where they lost to the Giants Redskins
Cowboys Cowboys and the 49ers then the
Cowboys then the Packers and then the
pack
yeah the Packers beat the [ __ ]
Patriots I went to that game then the
Broncos won the next two then the Rams
then the Ravens
stupid that coach there they have no
idea how fast we are shut up it clown
they beat the Giants then Patriots then
Tampa Patriots Patriots Colts Steelers
Giants Steelers nah you like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] Rain Man what do you wanna go
another sport name another sport I'll
[ __ ] do it I can go all the way back
to like the early 70s
that's what I'd actually [ __ ] sit
there and I write that down on like
napkins cocktail napkins when I'm on
planes like that's how I make plane
rides go by like right now maybe you're
on a plane listen to this [ __ ] I
actually sit there Green Bay Green Bay
Jets yeah definitely the Chiefs I know
I'm a [ __ ] loser all right let's get
to some of the questions here for the
week Jesus Christ Nia this is what
happens when I'm doing my [ __ ]
podcast Nia is always getting ready to
go somewhere and she comes out in all
sorts of [ __ ] different dress and I'm
not ready for it you just don't think
I'm gonna go do one of those Sports
Illustrated covers none of those ones
where they were the mesh bathing suit
yeah exactly
all right let's plow ahead here
questions of the week all right question
number one hey Bill I'm sure you by now
you've seen the punch just wondering
what your opinion was on it personally I
thought the Boise State player deserved
it and the expression on his face was
priceless
go blue all right there's a Michigan fan
or unless you're saying go blue because
of the [ __ ] turf okay how do I
explain this [ __ ] this is basically what
happened Boise State played played
Oregon and I guess last year Boise State
injured the quarterback on [ __ ] I was
just picturing that dude from England
getting all pissed let's send this [ __ ]
because I know he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about all this stuff but I don't give a
[ __ ] that you don't watch this stuff
I'll talk about the Premier League next
week
so anyways somebody in Boise State
injured the quarterback on Oregon so the
running back on Oregon said we owe Boise
State an ass-whooping so he was
basically talking [ __ ] so they play the
game and they held that guy
[ __ ] two minus five yards so at the end
of the game they came up and they talked
a little bit of [ __ ] the guy gets in his
face it's probably like what are you
gonna say now man what do you guys say
now and then the dude looks away and the
dude who was getting yelled at just
wound up and he [ __ ] drop the guy and
then and then it just got ugly and ugly
and ugly what do I think about that it
was definitely funny
there's definitely funny to see it
whenever you see a guy get in somebody's
face talking a bunch of [ __ ] and then
the other guy just you know just [ __ ]
winds up and drops um it was definitely
funny but I thought that dude had it
coming you know if you're gonna say you
know you got an ass-whooping coming if
you got a talk [ __ ] and then only get
minus five yards you got to understand
that people are gonna give you some [ __ ]
back and I gotta be honest man I feel
real bad for that guy because you know
he could have got drafted and now he got
suspended and that's one of those
heat-of-the-moment things were I don't
know it's at some point you know I mean
he might he just [ __ ] his whole life
up like now now he won't get drafted and
then what do you do you work at Best Buy
you could have you know you could have
got at least you know even if you suck
you're gonna get like six-figure
contract maybe for a couple of years you
run around and play for the [ __ ]
Chiefs or some [ __ ] like that I don't
know it was just really bad
it was [ __ ] ugly and and then the
fact that it was a black dude and he
punches a white dude then you go on the
internet and everybody has to write some
racist [ __ ] which is one of the things I
really can't stand about YouTube is all
the all the all the racists on there
I really can't [ __ ] stand that I
don't mind when someone writes some [ __ ]
just to be a dick to annoy somebody but
like yeah the n-word is used pretty
liberally on YouTube and that's the one
[ __ ] thing you know somebody asked me
that actually about my website was
saying like you know why don't you have
a page where people can you know leave
comments and stuff like that and that's
why I don't because people end up
arguing and then invariably somebody
writes something racist or something
just really horrific some about Jews or
something and then it's on my website
it's just a you know I don't condone
that [ __ ]
I just you know I don't give a [ __ ] what
I do the podcast you want to write
something or send it to me and I'll
[ __ ] read it on this I don't know
that I explained that I feel bad for
that guy I feel bad for that dude
because he just [ __ ] his life up in
one moment by punching the guy in the
face but you know Sam I don't like I
don't like when people sucker punch
somebody and then they had like that
yeah what what [ __ ] vibe what I mean
what I wasn't looking at you when you
punch me in the face yeah I'm gonna go
down that's really is really no skill
level there but in defense of that guy
if you do get in somebody's face and
talk [ __ ] yeah you what you do is that
you do that little you know that little
gay backwards skip that [ __ ] football
players do that's what you do while you
look at the person you don't say you
don't talk [ __ ] and then just [ __ ]
turn the other cheek like you're Jesus
you know do you think Jesus ever got
dropped with that whole [ __ ] way dude
he's did Jesus say that talk [ __ ] and
then turn the other cheek he didn't say
that he said if somebody slaps you turn
the other cheek so they can slap that
side what kind of a [ __ ] you know
what was me that's how I'm not religious
I can't get behind that son of God not
Son of God prophet or whatever that is
just some dumb [ __ ] son if somebody
kicks you in the left ball when you I
stopped watering and you can actually
see your right ball hold it out for him
so he can kick if that one go [ __ ]
yourself you [ __ ] hippie you stupid
ass sandals he really was the original
[ __ ] dirty ass hippy wasn't he wasn't
Jesus that all right that should get
some people sending me some emails god
help me if I ever get [ __ ] famous and
they start cutting up some of the
goddamn [ __ ] on this podcast I'm really
gonna be in trouble all right next
question bill did you ever at some point
in your early career think about
performing on a cruise ship this guy has
no idea how funny this question is I'm
not sure if you've ever taken a cruise
before but let me tell you it's pretty
[ __ ] sweet
[Music]
okay he says it seems like you literally
would be getting paid to go on vacation
get shit-faced daily and flirt with some
fine-ass trim in between all that if you
could find the time on Tuesday and
Thursday night to do your act for an
hour in the main showroom
not to mention you're waking up in some
of the sickest places in the Caribbean
every other day let me know what you
think all right
okay amongst comedians
you are never further out of show
business than when you do when you do
stand-up on a cruise ship people who do
stand-up on cruise ships it's basically
I don't know it's it's like there's two
places where you go out to pasture as a
performer Vegas and cruise ships Vegas
isn't bad because you'll get like a
million dollar [ __ ] like that Danny
Gans that guy who just [ __ ] passed
away like that guy was making millions
he had like he was making like five six
million a year he doesn't have to be on
the road you let the crowd come to you
there's a lot to say about that [ __ ] but
when you're out on a cruise ship I mean
first of all let's just break this whole
[ __ ] thing down it seems like you
literally beginning paid to go on a
vacation yeah except you have to work
that's actually one of the classic
things that club owners used to do when
I was starting out to try and [ __ ] you
over when they would try to book you
down in Florida in like the wintertime
and they'd offer you like 80 bucks for
the week or some awful [ __ ] and I'd be
like yeah but you know it's kind of like
you're on vacation it's kind of like a
paid vacation yeah except I have to work
except for that working part you [ __ ]
[ __ ] no a cruise ship is an absolute
[ __ ] nightmare believe it or not one
of the first things you want to do as a
performer the second the show is over is
you want to get the [ __ ] away from the
crowd you want to get away from the
crowd because the only way to describe
it is you you ever get stuck in an
elevator with some douchebag and you
have to make this small talk
conversation that you don't want to have
imagine being stuck on a boat with
[ __ ] a thousand of those people
because that's basically what it is now
I'm not
to be unappreciative of people who come
out to see the [ __ ] show but you know
I don't know what do you do for a living
okay let's use the plumber analogy does
that guy want to talk about fixing
[ __ ] toilets how did you get into
fixing toilet do you get nervous right
before you have to fix a toilet
you know it's awful
I did one cruise ship and I actually I
got fighting I get fired but I was
definitely not asked back and the whole
thing was a lie they told me I told him
first of all I said that my act is not
conducive to a cruise ship I just don't
see myself doing well on a cruise ship
and they were like you know because
people are old on cruise ships and they
like no this is a young hip cruise ship
I already told this [ __ ] story and I
got on there there was that old
Vietnamese woman passed out missing all
her [ __ ] teeth up front and I ate my
balls the entire week and the only
people I made laugh was the band you
know the captain wrote a letter saying I
was offensive to all [ __ ] people and
cruise ships are a nightmare sir they're
a [ __ ] nightmare
and I don't know what cruise ship that
you're taking but all I know is that
when I took a cruise ship they would
stop and you had basically four hours to
see whatever the [ __ ] you could see
before you had to run back to the ship
or they would leave without you so it
was a very stressful situation and then
other than that you were just out on the
water and it all looked the [ __ ] same
to me
maybe I didn't take a good one I mean if
I went to the Mediterranean and did a
European cruise I imagine that would be
cool but you know I don't want to go to
Athens for [ __ ] three hours you know
and [ __ ] sitting there running around
trying to see all the [ __ ] you know in
flip-flops and a [ __ ] Hawaiian shirt
you know just like Robin Williams before
he does a goddamn special it's it's a
nightmare gig sir
they definitely pay well but it is it's
it's a [ __ ] nightmare and you're out
to sea
and I don't know when I did them they
didn't even have internet access so
there was no way for your [ __ ] agent
to even get in contact with you if you
did have a big audition but even if you
did have a big auditions now you can
[ __ ] get off the boat you know call a
[ __ ] helicopter you know it's it's
terrific anyways let's plow ahead here
it's getting hot as [ __ ] here in my
apartment because I had to close the
windows because I curse
what is this section here something I
wasn't aware of I don't even know what
this is let me read this
the reason I'm writing you is I'm a huge
college football fan but I have to say
that there is one trend that has emerged
over the past decade that really bugs
the [ __ ] out of me oh this guy doesn't
like the promos I haven't has anybody
any other football fans known to this he
said why is it that every major football
telecast kicks off with some rednecks
singing a theme song I guess it started
with Hank Williams jr. now that's the
only one I know that I read it wasn't
football I'm gonna not partner I [ __ ]
hate that I don't like that one either
but I wasn't aware he's saying they're
doing it everywhere
he said it's gotten way out of hand a
few years ago College GameDay employed
its own country music band to sing the
show's theme song it's like the guy with
the fiddle and the guy wearing the big
top hat are supposed to be a little less
white trash because they're joined by a
black guy shouting out football audibles
in the middle of the song wow dude that
sounds [ __ ] horrific this year to top
it all off all the day apparently isn't
complete unless some other Appalachians
with a ten gallon hat sings the scene
theme song for ABC's Game of the Week on
Saturday night not to mention that
during the actual game the ACC has its
own commercial with some other Hicks
singing a theme song at least that is
somewhat understandable since the ACC is
predominantly a Southern Conference such
a [ __ ] all right look I get it college
football has a lot of fans in the
southeast part of the country football
in general attracts a large audience of
white males between the ages of 25 to 40
I am one of those white males and
frankly I'm a little tired of my
football viewing experience becoming
intruded on by an assorted cast of
characters from Hazzard County sorry for
the ramp but I had to get that off my
chest and frankly my wife couldn't care
less dude I'm in that boat I know that
you start rant to your girlfriend about
some [ __ ] and they just start glazing
over like yeah I really don't care about
sports so
at any point if you want to stop yelling
at me you're spitting on the side of my
face by the way yeah dude I got a mitt I
haven't noticed that [ __ ] but I'll tell
you why cuz I don't watch pregame or
postgame I don't I just watch the games
I don't want to watch that part where
people like you know I'll tell you you
know if I'm Terry Bradshaw I gotta be
thinking what's John Stallworth doing
but I don't give a [ __ ] you know and I
don't listen to sports talk radio all
those people [ __ ] freaking out losing
their minds oh they'll put the
second-stringer in relax that's why they
have coaches you don't have to worry
about it sir the decisions will be made
all right underrated overrated for the
weak underrated the television series
Brotherhood dude the Brotherhood was my
show and they actually cancelled it this
is what this guy has to say about he
says the crime show on Showtime was
recently cancelled was much better than
the similar The Sopranos it had superior
writing and acting it also had a better
place and its characters were much more
interesting
it could be just be that the whole
Italian mafia thing is getting tired
genre but but I got to go with
Brotherhood as overall being a better
show although they were both good
yeah the Brotherhood is awesome man if
you guys have a DVD store around you
what sucks is is there's two awesome
seasons and they're really the the
cliffhanger that they left you with it's
basically based on that I think the
Billy & whitey bulger thing we're back
in Massachusetts they had a really high
ranking politician whose brother was a
really high ranking gangster and this is
something else I think I already talked
about on the podcast yeah that was like
the dynamic and everyone would always be
asking the was I think was it was Billy
Billy Bulger I think was the politician
and whitey was the gangster and they
would always ask Billy be like what is
your affiliation you know I don't I
don't have any affiliation with my
brother you know Massachusetts my
brother I'm just trying to do the best
job I can due to the tax pay
of Massachusetts you know and the last
thing I thought I remembered happening
was the gangster actually won the state
lottery how [ __ ] hilarious is that so
this basically the show was based on
that took place in Providence Rhode
Island I highly highly [ __ ] recommend
that you watch it it sucks that there's
only two seasons but starts off a little
slow there's a lot of [ __ ] there's a
lot of characters but actually at one
point I'm actually gonna give away
something this is just sort of a little
vignette that they had on the show is a
Yankee fan comes into one of the
Providence bars and starts talking [ __ ]
to one of the hothead gangsters and
who's a Red Sox fan and he [ __ ] blows
his brains out and it was really it was
disturbing it was disturbing so
definitely check that out and that
[ __ ] guy was a great actor and not to
mention that the guy who plays Freddie
cork is actually believe it or not
because he's such a great [ __ ] actor
his Kevin Chapman was a comedian that I
started out with and he was one of my
fate that was one of my favorite
characters on TV and Tony V was in it
another great comedian from Boston I'm
so [ __ ] pissed that they canceled
that show cuz that was my show man I
love that show so I got to go with you
yeah Brotherhood definitely underrated
all right overrated this dude says the
Black Eyed Peas
the sheer amount of times I've heard the
new album against my will is staggering
the only people you'll catch listening
to them are the lame-ass want to be cool
white people who have never heard of
anything unless it was on the radio yeah
I know they definitely play them in
elevators and if you go to Staples I
can't even think of their [ __ ] music
but I can't stand uh did they do London
Bridge always that that chick when she
went solo oh that was Fergie by herself
oh that's right I'm sorry yeah you know
what I actually discovered the other day
uh I have a lot of [ __ ] my ipod that my
girlfriend downloaded when her [ __ ]
computer was on the blink and did I say
on the blink I don't know what the [ __ ]
that means
when it was on the fritz he so she
downloaded all this [ __ ] that I never
would
listen to so the other day what was that
song not crazy who sings that song
gnarls barkley I never she used to
listen to that song and I [ __ ] hated
it with that dude singing in that
falsetto you know but I actually
listened to the lyrics it's I actually
liked the song now I was at the gym
lifting weights listening to that song
and I've never felt gayer in my life I
got to wrap this up because that was
embarrassing to even admit that um
alright I'm 53 minutes in that's gonna
be the podcast this week I know it's a
little [ __ ] it was little off this
week I think but I'm coming down off a
Tylenol PM I had to do it I had to drug
myself up like [ __ ] Michael Jackson
so I could actually fall asleep by 2:00
at night so I could wake up and actually
try and do this thing at some point
remotely near Monday morning I hope you
enjoyed this podcast this week I hope
you guys had a great Labor Day weekend I
apologize I can't believe I deleted that
that rant that that boxer was doing it
was [ __ ] great the coach look out for
him he's a tough man and evidently he's
ready for more because he only started
bleeding he only started bleeding all
right that's it please continue listen
to podcast I'm gonna be at the helium
comedy club this weekend in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania please come down to the
show and also please join my mailing
list I never bring that up I would like
to get more people on my mailing list
because myspace is really dying a slow
pitiful death I barely get any emails
over there anymore and I don't know what
I don't know where to go next because I
imagine Facebook will take a nosedive
Twitter will take a nosedive and this
whole jumping around is driving me
[ __ ] nuts I figured out how to blog
here on my website and I'm gonna start
blogging actually began one about Sweden
that I will finish and hopefully I'll
get some new videos up there but it's
billboard.com if you could go on and you
sign up you just sign up for my mailing
list underneath the city that you're
closest to and basically I only send you
emails if I'm coming to your town or if
I'm gonna be on TV I'm not gonna be one
of these douchebags who every week gives
you the bill burr update and then I
become spam in your life it's not going
to be that way but please sign up
for it because my days on MySpace might
be numbered because I don't I don't know
that there's anybody left I'm really
feeling like [ __ ] Mad Max and I'm
there looking for fuel you know it's
just [ __ ] and people selling music
that's all that's left and me you know
tumbleweeds over there people all right
that's it that's the podcast for this
week please tune in next week wait a
second wait a second did you want to
chime in with something Nia oh that's
right Shawne Merriman choked out Tila
Tequila you know I exactly what do you
mean it's a podcast I got to make it
funny I don't like how you actually have
my you actually have my voice down like
you actually know what I'm gonna say no
that's not what I was gonna say I was
gonna say before I'm so rudely
interrupted with your completely
offensive
I don't like cat you know you have you
notice that with women whenever they do
an impression of their boyfriend they
always have to go before they say
anything I wanted to go out to go to a
restaurant and you know my boyfriend
said he was gonna take me and I was like
so we gonna go to the restaurant and
he's all would your football game I know
my impression of you it's really bad it
is bad do you want to go to a party this
weekend my girlfriend's what Ben
Roethlisberger that was that was a that
was a that was a cash grab he raped me
Ben Roethlisberger why don't you come
over here near the microphone if you're
actually gonna come in here in high
jacket here's my lovely girlfriend Nia
everybody hey let me just do this as
like an interview like a little dick
cavett thing what was your question here
in regards to tequila why are you being
so official the question that I had this
afternoon
and first of all I must say I love the
show and I'm really no but do you think
because I feel like and I guess we'll
see please get to the point man well
we'll see how the story develops but
like do you feel like the Michael Vick
thing got more attention than when
athletes to have like sort of like these
abuse charges
putting aside first of all Shawne
Merriman didn't have like 40 myspace
[ __ ] hung from trees that he was
electrocuting and drowning okay he
choked out one dumb [ __ ] with fake tits
a bisexual [ __ ] at that and I have to
say that I [ __ ] hate the San Diego
Chargers but my hatred went down a
little bit knowing that he slapped her
on Tila Tequila that's just funny if she
was if she was just you know a regular
you know girl from hooters whose dad
didn't stick around so she felt the need
to dress around scantily clad and try to
get guys attention you want to see my
clam if she was one of those people well
I'll tell you this I'll tell you this
right now and I might get I might get in
trouble here as I wade into these
dangerous waters how would you know that
well first of all what you storming out
you're gonna take off your little lapel
mic and just walk out all right
obviously I know they don't do that get
back here you can't you can't just leave
like that no they don't say I'm gonna
show you my clam but I will tell you
this when women get fake tits they will
show you them like they got their nails
done because obviously it was a very
insecure part of their body so now they
have it and they will it's so easy to
even be able to touch them they do just
all you got to do is like what their big
paranoia is now that they have them they
want you to tell them that they feel
real so all you got to do is just be
like you know other they look really
natural at Dee do you feel like they
feel yeah oh yeah here and they just
grab your hand for some reason because
their hand is on your hand they don't
feel like you're actually feeling them
up
you felt a fake boot before okay yeah
see well there you go
well we say nice what are they what do
they felt like a bag of sand really no
I'm actually I'm getting turned on by
this this is like this is really good
you know I got a lot of creeps who
listen to this so they're probably
touching themselves right now
they drive trucks helping out a little
no I'm not gonna [ __ ] out my girlfriend
on my own podcast you're a good girl
right
say it what are you wait a minute what
are you this is what you do at the
office you go around filling up girls
with fake tits well where was it when
you add [ __ ] in bill Haley's swimming
pool down the street I can never
remember people's names what's the name
of the [ __ ] guy who has playboy
Hector Camacho what's his name Hugh
Hefner I knew there was an H 9 I'm
brutal well that's one of the long
Hector Comacho is a boxer that's one of
the long-standing jokes in our
relationship is how this is what happens
is I can never remember famous people's
names so I just whatever the first name
that comes to my mind or the names of
movies like remember when I called that
movie the last days of Dracula what was
the name well what was that movie
interview with the vampire I called it
the last days last days of Dracula that
was a classic we have a lot of fun out
here don't we all right well we're gonna
we're gonna wrap up the podcast look how
cute cleo is over there with the ears
down yeah she's a cutie all right that's
the earth that's it for the podcast you
got a little bonus interview and that's
it I want to thank once again everybody
came out in Sweden I'm definitely gonna
come back there are you talking about
bringing me back there
and everybody in Philly I wrote a new
hour I'm gonna be there please sign up
for my my website and yeah if there's
out there with fake tits I'm telling you
don't have to ask too many questions and
they'll [ __ ] you know there's actually a
good chance they'll take them out if
you're in like a ground round one of
those kinds of restaurants were in that
restaurant we're always like I don't
know how they didn't get shut down by
the Health Department with all those
crushed peanut shells on the floor you
know you walked into a barber shop they
get a sweep up the hair how about you
sweep up the peanuts you from the
disgusting [ __ ]
all right have a good week I'll talk to
you later bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you